Lance Reddick The Talented actor from
The Wire the John Wick franchise and
more has died at the age of 60. TMZ
reports the actor was found dead in his
home in Studio City while redick's cause
of death is unknown law officials have
deemed it natural he has survived by his
wife Stephanie day Relic began his
career in the 1990s and gave memorable
supporting roles in the HBO dramas the
corner and oz in the early 2000s this
led to a main role on the influential
HBO drama the wire as Baltimore Police
Commissioner Cedric Daniels following
his stints on The Wire Reddick boasted
numerous performances on both the big
and small screen the actor worked with a
variety of iconic creatives during his
career including Spike Lee Roland
emmerich and Adam Wingard relic's
dominance extend into video games as
well the actor found himself stepping
into the role of Commander Zavala in
Bungie's critically acclaimed Destiny
franchise he also lent his Talons to
PlayStation and Guerrilla games's
Horizon zero Dawn and its 2022 sequel
forbidden West although his life has
been tragically cut short at a young age
the actor has fan bases across TV video
games and films to remember his work for
movie fans Reddit gave an engaging and
dynamic Turner Sharon a dedicated and
perceptive Hotel manager of the
Continental in NYC in all four John Wick
films the character offered him an
opportunity to explore his acting range
and deliver one of the most iconic
performances of his career shirvone was
first introduced in the first John Wick
film since then three sequels have been
commissioned with radic appearing in
each entry in the franchise reddick's
first posthumous role will be John Wick
chapter 4 which releases in late March
2023. the character has since gone on to
Define redick's career and has emerged
as one of the most popular supporting
roles in the John Wick franchise in a
2022 interview with CPR Lance Reddick
spoke at length about his role as Sharon
in the John Wick features when asked
what do into the character the actor
said it was the opportunity to play
against type he said the thing I love
about Sharon is that I've played so many
bombastic leaders that talk a lot so to
play someone who is just there to serve
who is very taciturn I never get to play
stuff like that how good is your laundry
I'm sorry to say that no one's that good
Lance Reddick will still have a number
of releases following his death
audiences will see him Grace the silver
scream on final time in Chevron in
ballerina the John wickspinner film
radic will also appear in the upcoming
Hulu exclusive White Men Can't Jump
remake perhaps the actor's most notable
posthumous release will be the Disney
plus adaptation of Percy Jackson and the
Olympians in which radical Star as Zeus
following Radix passing John Wick star
Keanu Reeves and franchise Helmer Chad
stahelski released a joint statement to
honor the late actor in the statement
obtained by deadline the duo said we are
deeply saddened and heartbroken at the
loss of our beloved friend and colleague
Lance Reddick he was a consummate
professional and a joy to work with he
also confirms that chapter 4 would be
dedicated in the actor's memory Winston
actor Ian McShane described as co-star
as both a wonderful human being and a
wonderful colleague in a subsequent
statement obtained by the outlet David
Simon the Creator behind the wire took
to Twitter following Radix passing to
pay tribute to the actor he wrote
consummate professional devoted
collaborator lovely and gentleman loyal
friend could go on but no I can't go on
this is gutting and way way way too soon
Reddick leaves behind an impressive
Legacy and will be missed by cinephiles
and Gamers all around the world
[Music]
foreign